the winner of the 1 million dollars and
the star of the headline show in Las
Vegas is bender
after weeks of intense competition
twelve-year-old singer-songwriter grace
van der Waal is the new winner of
America's Got Talent
you can feel the joy right after Grace's
big moment et's denne director was
backstage with all the proud judges and
of course the superstar in the making I
just heard that Dallas yeah you did
grace walk us through that moment when
they called your name you're not really
thinking you're just like oh my gosh oh
my gosh oh my gosh oh my gosh she is
amazing grace she is a shooting star
she's the brightest but I would be the
first person to buy a ticket to her
concert I'll be the first person in the
front row at Planet Hollywood in Vegas
watching you
her vibration her energy is real that
light is all over there girl
America was was deciding this and I'm
glad they chose her I think grace is
fantastic you know she really is a gift
to music you know for some reason it
reminded me of the Kelly Clarkson moment
I just thought you know you deserve this
so have you thought about what you're
going to do with that million dollars I
want to go on treehouse masters and get
a sick treehouse ziplines
Bridge is everything a lot of people who
are in your position or finally make it
in show business and they'll buy
themselves a mansion and that's what
makes her special that's what makes her
different she's moving out of her
parents house into her own tree
[Music]